i have a friend of mine
that uh he's been married to his wife
rolo for 15 years okay
she's a lawyer she makes a couple
hundred grand a year he's a stay-home
dad
and she's crazy about him she would
never leave him
and he has no desire
to go be a career guy he pick drops off
the kids in the morning makes them
breakfast
packs their lunch
and he's he's not a uh he's not a softy
like if you looked at him you wouldn't
be like oh this guy's a little pansies
he's not
and then they're happily married he's
not career driven he wants to be the
soccer dad is who he is he's exactly
what a soccer mom is except he's a
soccer dad she's not a cook he is and
they're happily married
and that's working out for them right
but i also have friends who will call me
and they'll say i said what's going on
us you seem like you're upset what's
pissing you off something's bothering
you well yeah listen man i mean i don't
know i'm like finally let's just say
we're having a conversation they'll open
up and they'll say you know
would it bother if your wife made more
money than you
he asked me this question opened the
question you know we're like three four
guys were talking shooting the
would it bother if your wife made more
money then i said why do you ask that's
what happened with me and my wife just
got a raise right now and we got some
fights at the house i said why does that
bother you well i feel like i have to be
the one making more money so
psychologically he couldn't accept it so
does that concept vary based on men and
women because sometimes i see women who
are stronger personalities marry a guy
who is not necessarily an alpha he's a
little bit more of a chill it's okay
nothing pisses him off and that works
out because
i think the one thing about these
philosophies is
from my experience i don't think there's
anything that's an absolute truth right
i think there's generalities and there's
a majority and then you got the
exception you know to the rule what
would you say to that okay well first
and foremost the idea that um that men
and women uh are equal is a misnomer
because i think what we do is when we
talk like
people throw me under the bus for this
one but i don't i don't believe in
equality and i don't mean that in the
terms of like oh we shouldn't all like
strive to be equal i just think that our
understanding what is
equal is sort of out
it's it's subjective and it's obscure
it's it's you know relative to whatever
uh the challenges are that uh men and
women
face in you know in life so if i wanted
to get pregnant i'm a man that i can't
do that because i'm a man so that seems
very unfair and unequal between the two
of us it just depends you can though
yeah well yeah apparently so apple
thinks you can can you pull up the new
emoji by apple apple things you can't i
don't know exactly i haven't figured out
yet but yeah but it's a painful
experience but but biologically speaking
reality objectively speaking there are
there are always going to be uh
differences between men and women and
how we define what's equality and what's
justice and what's fair and what's not
fair is really just dependent on what
the challenge is so if i'm flying out
here on the on the plane and some lady
says can you please put my bag in the
overhead because you're taller than i am
and you're stronger than i am and you
can put it up in the overhead well that
seems very no go we're all equal go
ahead you you do it right i'm not going
to defend you i don't we're all equal
today right no i'm going to go of course
pick it up and put it in there for her
but that's what i'm talking about what's
the challenge and the challenge in this
case is just simply taking your your
luggage and putting it in the overhead
bin right so
when we when we talk about equality we
need to say what's what's the challenge
under what parameters what's the context
that we're talking about here so when
you're talking about your friends who
are uh you know the man is sort of like
the mr mom right he's the stay-at-home
dad he wants to be the soccer soccer dad
or whatever else um odds are that what
does she do for a living a lawyer a
lawyer okay and what is what did he do
before he became this or how do they
meet i don't think he's ever had a full
time okay is he a good looking dude
there's probably something that offsets
you there's probably something that
offsets what do you mean he was he was
very handsome right now he's got a
massive belly and just uh he's got the
dad bod and he's just some women find
dad about hobbies yeah but that's what
i'm saying to you but here's the thing
though what are you going to change
about that's working they're good with
it and they've been together 15 years
are they doing something wrong so you
know that's not that's the another
exception that's what i'm saying that is
the exception i agree with that so all
i'm trying to say is the one part that
adam i will see
is
like you know in the company we have a
lot of couples in the sales company so
i'll see sometimes the wife is a bigger
alpha than the husband and he's okay
with that
like he doesn't have the insecurity of
saying i want to be the alpha that the
the fact that he doesn't have that
insecurity makes him an alpha i don't
know if that makes sense the fact that
he's not trying to impose is like dude
i'm i'm so happy and they're killing it
okay and he got some guys that are the
alpha and the wife is supportive and
some that run together but
that's that's very much an exception
because especially in blue-collar
couples i mean you're talking about
somebody who makes a lot of money in a
completely so different socio-economic
class you're looking at a larger whole
women
file for divorce 70 of the time and
that's the lowest estimate i have
actually have higher estimates as well
um and three out of four
so what precipitates that is usually
that woman has gone their blue collar
workers have the woman has gone up in in
status as a result of a promotion or
whatever and now the guy is making less
money or in the case of your friend here
he was never making that much money in
the first place now your lawyer friend
goes to you know the practice and she's
having to defer to men who are her
authorities who are her superiors guys
who are very powerful high status guys
that she has to interact with every day
is she going to come home from that
situation and go back to her soccer dad
husband and say yeah i will i'm gonna
submit to my husband i'm gonna you know
are we gonna suddenly come back into
that traditional conventional gender
role after working 40 hours a week with
guys who are much higher status than the
guy that she has to come home to every
day who's changing diapers and and you
know cooking mac and cheese so
that is the power dynamic that goes
along there because women are looking
for a man that they can look up to they
can women cannot look up to a man who is
her equal she's looking for a guy who
makes more money than she does she's
looking for a guy who is more on top of
his game as a quote unquote dominant
alpha male she's looking for the guy who
is is in status wise above herself if
there is some sort of anomaly that's
going on there where she's like oh i'm
good with it because he's a good-looking
guy
i would have to say well what's her
situation as well so it's not just about
like okay was he a good-looking dude as
you said he was what is her situation
again money muscles game and frame so
where does he fit in on those core four
right there um you can probably say
she's more attractive than him you would
say so you would say so okay so in that
case and he's not a porn star so yeah
yeah i know where you want to go you
know what i'm saying you know yeah well
i mean
you have to take that into consideration
right you have to say okay well she she
wants to get with this guy i mean i know
dozens and dozens of women who are
actually at least two of them are my
clients right now who complain that they
can't find the guy who is that higher
status guy and so they have to sort of
dumb themselves down i'm not saying you
should i'm saying they feel like they
have to dumb themselves down just so
they can get with a guy because more men
are simply not
average women don't want to get with
average men they want the guy who they
can look up to and admire and
from a
you know an average american uh
perspective like blue-collar workers
when that woman is elevated to a
different position that's what
precipitates divorce so if you enjoy
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]